the Joe Rogan experience got really
fascinated by the way you read because I
thought there was something wrong with
me by doing that but you you don't
really just read a book to completion
you read and then you pick something
else up and you just kind of go based on
your whims whatever you're interested in
well I was raised by my I was raised by
a single mom in New York and she used
the local library as a daycare center
because it was a very tough neighborhood
and so she would basically say when you
get back from the school go straight to
the library and don't come out until I
pick you up late at night so I used to
basically live in the library and I read
everything I read every magazine I read
every pictograph I read every book or
every map I just ran out of stuff to
read I just read everything so I got
over this idea of that reading a large
number of books or reading a book to
completion as a vanity metric because
really when people are putting up photos
on Twitter Instagram look at my pile of
books that I'm reading it's it's a
show-off thing it's a signaling thing
yeah and the reality is I would rather
read the best hundred books over and
over again until I absorb them rather
than read all the books right yeah
because your brain has finite
information in a finite space you get
enough advice at all cancels to zero
there's a lot of nonsense in books out
there too so I don't read anymore to
complete books I read to satisfy my
genuine intellectual curiosity and it
can be anything it could be nonsense it
could be history could be fiction it
could be science it can be sci-fi these
days it's mostly sci-fi philosophy
science because that's just what I'm
interested in but I will read for
understanding so a really good book I
will flip through I won't actually read
it consecutive in order and I won't even
miss leavin finish it I'm looking for
ideas things that I don't understand and
when I find something really interesting
I'll reflect on it I'll research it and
then when I'm bored of it I'll drop it
or I'll flip to another book
thanks to electronic books I've got
fifty seventy books open at any time in
my Kindle or iBooks and I'm just
bouncing around between them it's also a
little bit of a defense mechanism to how
in modern society we get too much
information too quickly and so our
attention spans are very low so you get
Twitter you get Instagram you get
Facebook you just used to be
bombarded with information so you can
take that too you can view that as a
negative and be like I have no attention
span or you could view that as a
positive i multitask really well and I
can dig really fast I can if I find a
thread that's interesting I can follow
through five social networks through the
web through the libraries through the
books and I can really get to the bottom
of this thing very quickly it's like the
Library of Alexandria that I can
research in my disposal so I longer
track books read or even care about
books read it's about understanding
concepts yeah you brought up two awesome
points first of all the the social media
aspect of books and basically anything
it's like it's such a weird way to
display your life because it's you know
you're displaying that the best aspects
of your life and some sort of a glass
case you know this it's an unrealistic
version of your life that you cultivate
and you curate and I'm I'm as guilty of
that as anybody everybody's guilty I'm
guilty of it too yeah I mean I posed
with my dog every time I run yeah we're
always signaling yeah it's like rather
than really looking at yourself you're
looking at how other people look at you
this one remove mental image and it's
kind of a disease because social media
is making celebrities of all of us and
celebrities and most miserable people in
the world right because they're this
strong self image that gets built up it
gets built up by compliments every time
somebody pays you and me a compliment
and we're like oh well thank you right
then that builds up an image of who we
are and then one idiot comes along one
out of ten one out of a hundred and they
can easily tear it down hmm
because it doesn't take many insults to
cancel out a lot of compliments and now
you're carrying around this big weighty
self-image it's just very easy to be
attacked and because you're you're
famous or you're well-known people want
to attack you so being a celebrity is no
good it's actually a problem like one of
my tweets is and these are all reminders
to myself is you want to be rich in an
anonymous not poor and famous hmm
there's benefits to it of course but we
wouldn't do it it has unusual problems
that you don't get trained for and you
really will not understand unless you
experience it
[Applause]